contre lui ta carte la pièce d'identité
d'un soldat au rapport pour la piquant
mais tu lui ressemble pas du tout ce qui
rassemble un soldat j'ai trop hâte on se
casse mais autant de bagages
arrête de mater mais sutil gros pervers
feras tu leur a pas dit qu'on venait
j'étais en train de le faire mais bon du
coup c'est toi qui vient de leur
annoncer
jérémy a dit qu'on allait faire un petit
kilomètre dans la forêt j'ai un petit
cadeau c'est pour tous rebecchi une
capote 3 de la bge et qui a toujours eu
un faible pour toi je prends mon temps
pour dévoiler les quartiers dans un jeu
de merde bordel c'est bien beau la
nature on n'a toujours pas qui collait
[Musique]
pas vraiment trop envie de sauter ces
partis fin sauf que moi je vais utiliser
la méthode sun
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé ça assez marrant finale où
cette lame et si tranchant qu'est ce qui
raccourcit attends tu viens d'où
alors oui j'ai besoin qu'on m'envoie un
hélico pour évacuer un blessé
pour attirer l'attention qui a eu l'idée
et attiser le feu
oui c'est moi monsieur p complètement
taré quel truc de dingue
waouh le roi de la belle avait
l'intention de s'en servir ici à
l'hôpital
[Musique]
non
tu sens et passer un week end tranquille
chan tu viens ouais c'est quoi ton
problème avoue tubes en seconde pas du
tout ce talent chez avant non c'est le
siège j'hallucine tadine gaz tubes en
danger pas caser je bande pas je suis ce
qu'il ya au moins un mensonge
qu'est ce que tu as à faire qu'on classe